the amazing viral video market watch
reports walgreens shoplifter fills trash
bag with stolen goods and bikes out of
store
bay area retail theft has seen walgreens
close 17 san francisco stores in the
last five years look at this amazing
photograph for those that are just
listening i'll describe it
there's a woman and she's like
exasperated with her hand up as the
security guard is literally just filming
the guy and the dude's stuffing what
looks like what's like a 25 gallon
shopping garbage bag he's just dumping
things off the wall i wonder what he's
stealing what are they like they're like
the eye care aisle i think personal
goods personal usually what's behind
that little wall what do you mean
personal goods what's that deodorant
deodorant this dude is stealing all the
deodorant i don't know that he's
stealing all the detroit how dare he but
then he just hops on his bike and rides
away and that's it
that's it that's what's been happening
in in in san francisco so apparently
there was this uh proposition back in
2014 that was pushed obviously by the
democrat super majority that would make
any shoplifting under 950 dollars a
misdemeanor
and at that point cops were like well
you know we're not going to respond to
these calls anymore once the cops stop
responding more and more people start
committing these crimes more people
committing crimes means the cops can't
respond to everybody so now it's just
it's a riot like literally i would
describe this as san francisco is in a
permanent state of rioting
it's a permanent state of shoplifting
for sure
but but or looting we'll call it looting
i think it is that and it's because the
police officers obviously aren't going
to
prosecute these misdemeanor crimes
there's nothing for them to
go pick these people up and also people
are just going to get released as soon
as they're arrested anyway so even if
they were to arrest people for these
misdemeanors the da's just going to let
them go it's completely pointless
policing would you want to live there
you know i would not in fact don't you
live in new york i do but new york is
different although i will say that uh
the last time i went to rite aid and i
tried to pick up some gum it was in a
locked box and i had to take it it was
gum gum gum it was like a it was a four
pack you know so that's serious money
right but i had to take it up to the
front to get it uh released from the
locked from the locked box another thing
that's really incredible here really
stupid is that a lot of these stores are
closing down in droves i'm hearing
estimates of 17 dwayne reeds being
closed in california because of the
constant theft because they can't 17
wall greens in san francisco
specifically yeah yeah they can't make
any money because people are just coming
in taking whatever they want and then
the security guard i mean that was the
most hilarious part of the the video
that not many people picked up because
it was it was saw it was so awesome to
see the security guards literally
standing there like and then the lady
next to him was like hey should we call
9-1-1 and the security guard is like no
no i stand the security guard security
guards getting paid what like 10 bucks
an hour the cops don't support the
stores anymore the laws that have been
passed are just it's happening every day
i'm i'm with the security guard in this
one i'd be like
back yeah right back in i think what was
it
1998 i was working at a hat shop in
philadelphia uh
i don't even know if there's hat shops
anymore but i was working there and
there used to be this guy who would come
in every couple of days and steal a
stack of hats and it was just me at the
store a stack like a full ass like stack
of hats
and he'd walk into the store and i'd be
like hello again how are you and he's
you know i'm gonna take these hats
okay yeah he'd be like i'm gonna take
these hats i was i don't know i was 20.
i don't know no wait don't yeah and i
was like okay well when you take the
hats i'm gonna call the police and he's
like yes i know you're going to call the
police he walked out of the store with
the hats i called the police two hours
later they show up i'm already closing
the store i file the report
i was walking home from work one of the
days
and there he was on the street with a
blanket laid out with all the hats and i
was like hey how's it going he was like
how'd that work out for
oh you amazing yeah and that was that he
should have at least given you one of
the heads you know he really should have
my boss who was this woman who was kind
of badass she was like you have to go
after that guy and i was like nah
nah i'm not doing that i can't believe i
can't possibly do that i'm 20 i'm high
like i'm not
add at four dollars an hour and we'll
attack on security yeah maybe
yeah
i mean i was working at sunglass at
university and
i mean we used to get robbed constantly
but they told us like that was a policy
it's like you don't go after the thieves
i mean especially in san francisco like
you don't know if they have weapons are
you really gonna like the security guard
how much is he getting paid 20 bucks an
hour he's gonna risk getting stabbed or
whatever for deodorant is that what you
said yeah yeah
there is zero incentive for the cops and
even less for the security guard well so
think about this problem i mean
how do you how do you how do you solve
it then right i think i think it's i
think it's you're right
the guy's stealing much of deodorant why
should i care
however if you don't stop this guy what
happens
everyone starts doing it it's a
permanent state of looting well and
that's what's going on and this was a
terrible law it should never have been
passed i think that's clear and it also
laws like this i think it was what like
prop 47 or something laws like this
are completely they go against what the
liberals are trying to do anyway because
once you have all of these
places shutting down you're recreating
the food deserts that so many city
policies were trying to
avoid
so
who's going to open a grocery store in
an area with high crime and then the
people who live in that area aren't
going to have any food and then you're
going to have a food desert and then
you're going to have an obesity problem
and it's just going to compound
actually one of the things i was reading
about when the walgreens started
shutting down elderly people who live in
san francisco can't get their
medications anymore because there was
one story about a guy who used to walk
downstairs and then walk 10 feet to the
i think it was like a duane reader or
whatever cvs they closed down because of
all the shoplifting now he's got to walk
miles like one or two miles to actually
get to his pharmacy now and it's only a
matter of time before they all shut down
you know my favorite thing about all
this though is
one of the remedies to all the
shoplifting has been they started
putting the items that are getting
stolen in lock boxes
like my gum
well what happened was
the item so there's there's a photo that
went viral showing uh like hair care
products and the hair care products for
black people were in a lock box and the
ones for white people weren't and the
left started saying it was racist and it
was interesting because i'm sure the
manager and the corporation did not go
out there and say oh you know we're
going to do this because the company is
racist and lock up only the the ethnic
minority here they were probably just
looking at a list of like things that
were getting stolen and said if it's
getting stolen lock it up and some
guy who has no idea what's going on just
goes okay product 17 and product 34. now
to stop the shoplifting they're all
racist i guess the other thing too is
that because so many of these stores are
just corporate
chains you don't have anyone who's
working at the store who really cares
what goes on at the shop yeah it's not
like a local pharmacy that's run by a
family or whatever who's going to
actually care about what happens there
well i think another aspect we're not
really considering here is maybe the guy
thought it was a amazon cashless store
it was just walking out i mean that's
also a possibility here with his mask on
it it was it was a mask for cover he was
just trying to consider it but in all
seriousness i remember being in san
francisco two years ago investigating
the crime that has been happening there
and it's been slowly escalating ever
since i remember walking and just
talking about the poop on the street
which there's
an exorbitant amount of people
literally taking a crap in the middle of
downtown san francisco i remember
reporting on this walking by and there's
a woman screaming on the top of her
lungs running across the street
jaywalking there's police officers
behind me as i was doing the walking
talk police officers heard this woman's
scream in the video you can see this
right now uh youtube.comchain san
francisco and then the cops just decide
to walk the other way and i'm like what
the hell am i experiencing where
literally people are
some would say right now that they're
vaccinating themselves in the middle of
the streets they're not doing that
they're just trying to be wearing masks
because i don't think i don't think
they're that available i think they're
injecting something else into their
veins into the middle in the middle of
the street but it was it was like a
zombie apocalypse wasteland two years
ago and now to see this these stories
and see it escalate and to talk to
people who are there i mean we're
talking about the center of tech
entrepreneurs we're talking about
silicon valley we're talking about some
of the richest most influential people
in the world who voted for this
now having to deal with the
ramifications of this here's the best
part
during the lockdowns
all we couldn't go to the bars we
couldn't go to churches there was no
water cooler there was no conversation
you couldn't see your neighbors
if you were going to see anything in the
news it had to go through twitter and
facebook and youtube and whatever big
tech platform
if you wanted to buy a book it had to be
on amazon or you had to go to you know
probably just amazon to be honest
and these people from san francisco are
regulating the opinions on these
platforms which means the world view
that created the nightmare dystopia that
has san francisco
it's being perpetuated through these
platforms even right now even with the
lockdowns being lifted and our ability
to go out and see movies and talk and
hang out still for the most part our
opinions are sent through this filter of
the big tech oligarchs
you look at how they run where they live
their opinions should not be the ones
we're propping up but that's exactly
what's happening so it's only a matter
of time to be honest well and these are
also people who didn't ever consider
ethics they're only considering
algorithms and things like that they've
never looked into the actual effects of
what they're doing and nobody ever
taught them how to do any of that stuff
because we completely depleted our
educational system so that what do you
do you major in marketing and memes
which
okay that's interesting i suppose but it
would help to have some measure of
philosophy and understanding of
political discourse and perhaps history
that isn't entirely filtered through the
lens of whether or not it's racist i i
feel like a big component is it's it
well i'll put it this way it's funny
that there's some capitalist criticism
but then we also have this very serious
problem of critical race theory ideology
in our schools you on one hand have
college where it's like a large
component is ridiculous jobs that are
just for making money but now colleges
are being taken over by really
ridiculous majors that have nothing to
do we'll never make money so it's you
can either have the one extreme of like
you said you're studying memes because
memes make money for advertisers or
whatever or
critical race theory and you know gender
sciences and studies which don't produce
anything for society hey there's nothing
wrong with memes okay i love the memes
beams are amazing but but also another
thing we have to understand here major
you could actually get yeah
it's probably the most useful one that
you can actually get the best money for
yourself it's a component for marketing
right but about a lot so we had a
problem for a while where a lot of jobs
we had were pointless like the internet
gets invented and then i mean look no
disrespect to my friends who work at
fast food but a lot of these cashiers
are being replaced by kiosks well
they're being replaced by kiosks in part
because the minimum wage is going up to
15 an hour and mcdonald's for example
doesn't want any part of that so thanks
joe biden for eliminating a bunch of
entry-level jobs that could have taught
young people how to have a job and show
up on time there's also the issue of
unfettered immigration creating
low-skill competition for those young
people
and then the young people actually don't
end up working these places anyway then
they're told by their parents to skip
these jobs and go straight to college
then they get indoctrinated with
ridiculous ideology and then they get
out and they're like why can't i get a
job in a newsroom with a gender studies
degree and it's like because you're an
idiot did you see the thing now where
the cbc i don't know if you follow the
canadian broadcasting company but
they've decided to suspend all
commenting for articles on facebook
because they don't want their reporters
and journalists to feel bad when there's
negative feedback
for their stories it's such the the
stupidest and most fake argument i'll
tell you this right there's a bunch of
stupid like cringy leftists who are
tweeting outrage that cassandra has
joined and she's going to be running the
newsroom with that i don't care i'm like
dude you like you you guys you'll
literally get fired by your boss in two
seconds if you say like fart you know
what i mean you just went off and were
screaming at this ap reporter who got
fired for having bad opinions and you
know what i'll eat this one i was
actually saying well maybe ap shouldn't
hire her and now there's there's equal
criticism to me because cassandra
certainly got feisty opinions as well
all right so i'll walk maybe i'm wrong
maybe we just don't have you know you
have your reporters focus on like if
they're going to be opinionated on one
thing maybe they should cover something
else so so i'll i'll take that criticism
but how are you going to come out taylor
lorenz who uh i i don't have the biggest
issue with but i understand why people
are upset with her in the things she
posts for the new york times she's she
complains all day and night about
journalists getting harassed and how
it's wrong especially women journalists
and now what i've got cassandra and she
wrote she's written five articles
they're all very straightforward regular
news and the left is screaming like it's
the apocalypse digging up her old tweets
and posting them and tweeting at me
i'm like is this a harassment campaign
because you know when you come out and
complain that we tweet at journalists
and then you tweet at me you think i'm
gonna have any sympathy for you not
you're all are nuts all right thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time